hi this is press talker let's discuss
the braised paradox which states that
adding a road could possibly slow down
traffic this is a counterintuitive
phenomenon but researchers have actually
identified roads where the existence of
these roads slows down traffic and
actually closing those roads could speed
up traffic and these are in busy areas
like New York City Boston and even
London so how is this possible we need
to go through a mathematical example
imagine you're traveling from A to B but
you can't travel directly you have to
travel on one of these routes some of
the roads take 20 minutes flat whereas
other roads take T over 10 minutes where
T depends on the level of traffic we can
ask how long would it take for 200
drivers to go along this network it's
pretty easy to see the roads are equally
preferable so the 200 drivers would
split up T equals 100 to each route that
would make the traffic dependent roads
take ten minutes each and therefore the
total travel time from A to B would be
30 minutes we can consider the same
exact network of roads and the same
travel times but we'll add one more road
this road takes zero minutes and allows
us to travel between the two routes now
what will the travel time be one
observation is that T over ten will
always be less than or equal to 20
minutes even if all drivers take that
road therefore the T over ten roads are
always preferable so all 200 drivers
take these roads and they take 20
minutes each
and therefore the total travel time will
be 40 minutes to get from A to B and
this is the braised paradox Illustrated
before we had the free road the travel
time was 30 minutes and the free Road
made the travel time 40 minutes because
everyone got congested on the same Road
this has many applications in physics we
can look at the distance of a spring in
basketball explains the Ewing paradox
and it can even happen in electricity
transmission which is also network if
you liked this video please get my book
the joy of game theory which covers such
interesting topics and please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can support me on
patreon catch me on my blog minor
decisions on Twitter at fresh hollow
occur and you can get all of my books
and Amazon